we know that in order for transcription
to start we need the minimal requirement
of general transcription factors and RNA
polymerase apart from general
transcription factor there are other
transcription factors in a specialized
transcription factor which binds to
specific regions on the DNA and recruits
activator or repressor and thereby
regulating the transcription now how a
transcription factor binds to the DNA is
a question of interest it turns out that
in transcription factor there are
specific DNA binding motifs which
ensures the specificity of that
specialized transcription factor to find
in a sequence specific manner and
thereby activating or depressing
transcription in this video we would get
an overview of several DNA binding
motifs used by the transcription factors
to bind to the DNA first we would talk
about helices turn headaches motive or
HTH motif HTH motif has two alpha helix
followed by a bitter turn and it binds
to the major groove of the DNA and h th
motif is roughly 20 to 25 amino acid
long now h th motive binds to the major
proof of the DNA through various
interactions like hydrogen bond fangirls
interaction etc so the residues that are
exposed in the major group from the h th
protein is actually binding to the
specific bases in the DNA now for
example there are specific groups out of
the h th motive for example tryptophan
or lysine that interacts with the bases
aromatic bases in the TNA lambda
repressor which is important for lytic
analyser genex which in case of
bacteriophage is also having the same
DNA binding motif that means the h th
motif so that's why
motives function is pretty much
conserved from bacteria to human for
example another important classes of
transcription factors known as commuter
wind containing transcription factors
which are highly conserved with the 60
amino acids encoded by a 180 base pair
long T in a segment termed as homeobox
have also this similar kind of structure
that means he'll stand Hennings but
instead of two helix it has three
headings and this Elex turn helix
containing homeodomain containing
transcription factors are very important
for segment polarity and patterning of
both from a flight to a memory and
embryo
another important DNA bonding motive is
hellix loop headaches
as the name suggests there are two helix
and connected by a loop now these
headaches loop helix containing
transcription factor could form
homodimer or heterodimer in this example
it has been shown that they are forming
a heterodimer now there are leucine
zipper motives which are also very
important DNA binding proteins and it
conspires of busy family now busy
domains having 60 to 80 M University now
the leucine zipper has two broad
structural importance one is at the end
of it it has multiple loosing residues
which are interacting with each other by
hydrophobic interaction and the region
that interacts with the DNA's major
groups has several protrusion it has a
arginine residue which protrudes out
from the leucine zipper and interacts
with the one in residue of the DNA and
this specific interaction determines
that whether these leucine zippers would
bind to the specific sequences on the
DNA specific regulatory elements of the
DNA now the example of this reduced
zipper is false or true false in June at
the end transcription factors activated
by the map kinase signaling pathway
false has leucine zipper motifs not only
false June c/ebp all has this same
leucine zipper DNA binding motif and
they're thereby being tracked to
specific ap1 family of transcription
binding region now another important
motive is the zinc finger motif zinc
finger motif as the name suggests it has
one or more than one zinc ion
coordinated by several aromatic groups
protruding out of these multiple alpha
helix and beta turns so these also bind
to the major groove of the DNA and the
specific amino acids which are
protruding out of these harris's or beta
pleated sheets they interact with the
DNA they interact with the specific
bases of the DNA and ensures that the
specificity of binding is not maintained
the example of these zinc finger are
steroid receptors and thyroid hormone
receptors thyroid hormone receptor is in
its a nuclear receptor that means it's
present in the nucleus once thyroid
binds it activates or replaces
transcription by interaction with
co-activator and cold pressor now these
thyroid hormone receptor has zinc finger
has DNA binding motif and this same
finger has specific to cysteine and two
histidine residues that interacts with
specific region of the DNA known as
thyroid response element and the
specificity of the binding is ensured by
specific amino acids for shooting out of
the zinc finger and thereby the zinc
finger containing thyroid receptor which
is a nuclear transcription factor can
bind to the thyroid responsive element
and give rise to transcription so that
was an overview of all the DNA binding
motifs and the most common DNA binding
motifs
you like my videos even a quick comes up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
in my another video I would describe all
these DNA binding motive individually in
lot more details so stay tuned thank you